Excuse me, you look a little hungry there
Could I perhaps, interest you in a snack?
Have you tried the new Sandpockets?
They're delicious.
Give them a go
Mmmm
No?
Not your flavor?
Have you tried the new VHS Static flavor?
Tastes just like ants. Oh really? You're a snob, huh?
Well, how about a Hot pocket package pocket
Now that's meta
Oh no?
Well, how about a hot pockets nails?
That's for my haters
It's still crispy and buttery (mmmm buttery)
NO? Well, how about hot pocket caviar with quail eggs, and brie?
See, I can tell that you are a person of a finer taste because oh boy, that looks delicious
Okay, now...
If you don't want any of these flavors, I don't know what to tell you?
Okay? You're gonna have to just decide on something, please bees and used medical needles...(i'm allergic to bees so no thank you Pewds)
Okay, we're running out of flavors here, please. All right, I think I know what you want.
I can tell by looking you in the eyes, what you want is hot pocket dryer lint. (uh I'll pass)
Listen up, listen up. You don't know if you don't like it. Unless you tried it. Give it a go!
It's nice and steamy. It's nice and soft.
It makes your mouth feel like dust, enjoy.
You want gluten free, you want dairy free
You want egg free, you want meat free. You want food free and you want water free and you want air free. (holy shit yes)
Please enjoy. How about the blank PNG? *laughs*
Please accept the *demon sounds*
Excuse me for getting angry, you're a man of culture, a man of the finer, finer, FINER taste.
I know just the thing.
Anime thighs! That's right everybody
Anime thighs!
Mmm doesn't get any more delish than some anime thighs, just so nice! Who love - who doesn't love a thigh?
especially if it's from an...
anime...
picture.
EMOTIONLESS VOID, because that is what you are. If you won't have my pot pockets. I don't know what to tell you?
Maybe you want the Africa flavored edition: Nothing. How about the cancer cell hot pockets?!
How much can I keep going with this? *emotionally breaking down*
Literally, THERE'S JUST AN EFFING DOG IN THERE!!!!!
I'M DONE HOTPOCKETS!
I'M DONE!
I'VE HAD ENOUGH!
There's only so much a man can endure.
The hot pockets meme. This is an older meme, which is why there's so many
But they really just never end.
It's one of those memes that just keep on floating
Until I got my hands on it!
*Intense fighting*
*Clap* It gets a six I quite like it.
*fart noise*
I've never actually had a hot pocket
Are they- are they good?
Which flavour would you pick? Leave a comment down below
*Clap Clap*
Next meme
This meme... guys is blowing up
*Intense dabbing*
*Still dabbing* Prepare for blowing up meme montage
This is going to be great
"Do you have a better idea?
"Yes, I do"
"Minecraft seto where you need to survive all day and night
Craft a diamond sword so you can fi - if anyone has a question
Hey, do you have a better idea about what we can do,
Just hit 'em with this,
Hit 'em with the:
*Beautiful singing* Minecraft theto
Enderdragon in my direction
Many XP, It's such a blessing. Yeah
Use all the XP to enchant my armour yeah
Yeah oooOOooOOaaaAAaa
I try to sleep on the darkest day
but the mobs are in the way...
Gotta kill them so I can go to bed (10/10 Pewds, nice singing)
This armour's really comfy when I put it on,
*Pewds singing gibberish
I see a village that is near the only sounds I wanna hear,
*Pewds singing gibberish again*
Smelt, smelt the iron so I can get some metal
*Pewds singing gibberish for the third time*
Oh yeah,
*Pewds singing gibberish for the fourth time*
*Interrupts with laughing*
Was she playing this whole time Alexa, shut the f**k up
Jesus Christ no one asked, literally no one asked Alexa, no one, where was i?
"Do you have a better idea?"
Sometimes you just never have a better idea
"Do you have a better idea?""
"Yes, I do"
Okay, what is it gonna play?
You're in the trenches, it's World War one. The Germans are coming. What do you do? Alexa?
play oppa gangnam style
*Pewds rages*
"Do you have a better idea?"
"Yes, I do"
*Fortnite music*
How do they do the dance?
*Weird noises from Pewds*
I can do the dance!!
Yeeeeeess
What is happening?
Help me
I'm supposed to review the memes
"Do you have a better idea?"
"Yes, I do."
*Ali-a intro earrape version*
Oh my god the Ali-a meme!
Pshh, never SEEN THAT ONE!
"Do you have a better idea?"
"Yes, I do.
DEJA VU
I have been in this place before...
I don't this meme is really not working that great.
*clap clap*
This meme gets 5/7...Yes, i do.
no no no NO NO NOOO
UUUUuuuuuAAAAAAaaaaa
Zero...Alexa play zero
*felix says fuck but music plays over it*
Alexa what would you rate this meme?
Alexa are you actually? *he says ugly words again*
Meme review...YouTube's memest show everybody. We got memes, alright? Alexa? How old is Amy Schumer?
Okay, all right
Shut up *ugly word* for a second Alexa? What is the average lifespan of a blue whale?
No, no, NOOO
Alexa this is so sad. Can we play despacito number 5? Volume to the max?
Many XP is such a blessing. Yeah, use all the XP to enchant my armor. Yeah
Ohhhh I
Try to sleep my darkest day
Alexa
Alexa!!
ALEXAAAA!!!!!!
Quiet please :)
How old is the Rock? 46 years. How long does rocks live?
No, not the Dwayne the rock Johnson Who am I going to watch fight a giant creature, climb a giant tower?
Or just do something that I don't really care about? damn it. This is so sad
Alexa can we onions please? I
I didn't ask! How long does ice cream last? No, two to three months? Oh No
Why do people have to die? Alexa? How old is lil pump?
Alexa, shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up. What is the life expectancy of pumps?
18 years ma. Ma person everybody. Can we get a thousand likes on this video?
Cuz he's about to get smacked and I bet you he is not even going to heaven
How old is Eminem? forty five years? How long do m&ms live? Noo... Do they actually live?
No, they don't that's fake. How old is pitbull? Oh No
People's live only 37 years. This is so sad. Wait. He's actually only 37?
I thought he was like 57.
How long does barry bee benson live?
Only one more day apparently
How old is the how old is meme?
Three days how long do memes live in 2018 two to five days
Well bonus point for this meme for being extra woke because that's that's pretty true
And you don't see a lot of memes lasting more than a week these days
some just sorta come and go
I don't know
Dude that rhymes!
how old is the girl reading this?
around 20 years
how long does an angel live?
Oh...
How old is the person watching this video?
9 years
How old does epic people that smash like on the video live?
Forever!!!
That's amazing!
Dude, I feel great about this. I have a good feeling about this relationship
How old is Tom Cruise?
Average length of a cruise
The average length of cruises is nearly seven days
HMMMMMMMmmmMMMMMmmmmm????!!!!
This makes zero sense
What the heck
If a meme is going to be funny,
At least make it funny
*while clapping* how old is pewdiepie?
28 years
How long do pies live?
Ah no, ah damn it. Ah Alexa, this is so sad for real
can we play an actual sad song that makes everyone just feels like
Do you know what this was a bit of a trash meme episode but at least I can embrace this melancholic feeling
*Starship - Nothing's Gonna Stop Us Now*
Thank you guys for watching
Another episode of meme review. I'm your host Felix Kjellburg and I'll see you guys next time (subtil made by nightfighter4)
wait
where is the ass video
oh ok we gucci